- Good afternoon everybody,
and welcome to Net 313,
where we'll be talking
about some encryption
in transit today.
My name's Scott Morrison. I'm
a Networking SA here at AWS.
This will be my, I think, fifth re:Invent
that I've presented at,
and my seventh year at AWS.
And I'll say that after
seven years at AWS,
I've gotten to know a lot
about how our network operates
under the hood,
where all the packets are
going through our network,
what's happening to them,
and it's lost a little bit of
the mystery after seven years.
But then I come to re:Invent,
I get to meet with all
of our great customers
and see the mystery that still happens
of how the network works at AWS.
And so today we're gonna unwrap
a little bit of that mystery
for you, talk about how some
of that encryption works at AWS
on our network and some
great new features related
to VPC encryption controls.
So with that, I'm gonna bring on my peer
and a product manager
for VPC, Akshay Choudhry
to take it over
and talk a little bit about
VPC encryption controls,
and then I'll be back
with you in a few minutes,
talk more about encryption.
Akshay.
- Good afternoon everyone.
My name is Akshay Choudhry.
I lead the product management
team here at AWS for VPC.
So here I'll first introduce encryption.
I'll talk about what is encryption,
how do you implement it,
how it has evolved over the time,
and then I'll talk about the challenges
in implementing encryption.
And with that, I'll talk
about how AWS is solving many
of those challenges
by offering native encryption
across multiple network paths.
And after that, I'll
introduce this new feature
of VPC encryption controls.
We launched it two weeks back.
This feature helps you
monitor the encryption status
of your traffic flows,
and it also helps you identify workloads
that are not enforcing encryption.
And it offers you tools to
enforce encryption in transit
across your environment in a region.
A lot has gone into building this feature,
and we would love for you folks to go back
and try your hand at this
feature and give us feedback.
One thing that is common across
all the successful features
at AWS is that we got a lot of
feedback from our customers,
about what they expect
from these features.
And then we kept working on those feedback
and we improved it over time.
And we would really
appreciate your support
in doing the same with
VPC encryption controls.
And after I've discussed the details
of how to set a VPC encryption controls
and what it does,
I'll hand over the stage
to my co-presenter, Scott,
who will discuss encryption strategies
and the emerging encryption frontiers.
So with that, encryption,
what is encryption?
Encryption is the process by
which you protect your data
from getting snooped on or
from getting compromised
by scrambling it using some logic.
So in this example,
suppose the sender wants
to send a simple text,
"Welcome to re:Invent!",
so what they would do is
they would use some logic
to scramble it with the expectation
that only the intended
receiver can unscramble it
and look at the original message.
This way, someone who's not intended
to see this message will
never see the original text.
So encryption has been
known to exist since 100 BC.
Back then, it was used
for secure communications
between military factions
and it was called Caesar cipher.
It used to be pretty simple back then.
It used to consist of some
alphabetic substitutions.
With time, the attackers
got more sophisticated
and they knew how to decipher
the simple encryption.
And with that, the encryption also evolved
to make it more difficult for
any attackers to decipher it.
So we have evidence that
around 15th century,
the encryption consisted of
polyalphabetic substitutions.
And then in World War II, Germany came out
with the Enigma Machine to
encrypt all their communication.
And back then it was
considered unbreakable
until Alan Turing developed
a machine to decipher those
or to break that encryption.
And that machine was the first computer,
that led to the invention
of the first computer.
But until now, there was no
one set standard worldwide
for encryption.
But in 1977, there were worldwide,
there were encryption standards
that were used worldwide
and those were DES,
which is Digital Encryption
Standard and RSA.
And today, the most prominently
used encryption standard
is Advanced Encryption Standard.
You may have heard of AES,
that's Advanced Encryption Standard.
And it comes with different key lengths
and we'll discuss about
these things later.
And today, the Post Quantum
Cryptography is also picking up.
Scott will talk more about it,
but Post Quantum Cryptography
is considered to be safe,
even from attackers who use
quantum computers to break it.
With that, let's look
at how encryption works.
We are looking at the old
example that we looked
where the sender wants
to send this simple text,
"Welcome to re:Invent!"
What the sender does is before
sending this message out,
the sender will use a
cryptographic mathematical model
to derive a key using which
they would encrypt this
or scramble this text.
Once they've scrambled it,
they use the same mathematical model
to derive another complementary key
that can be used to
unscramble or decrypt it.
And once, and let's call
that the receiver key.
Once they have that complementary key,
they find a way to
securely transmit that key
to the receiver.
When the receiver receives the key,
they're able to decrypt the traffic
and look at the original message.
Now, when the sender key and
the receiver key are different,
it's called asymmetric encryption.
And when they're same, it's
called symmetric encryption.
Worldwide, the most common
encryption standard uses
symmetric encryption today.
Now, you may have noticed two things here.
One is that, it takes
some computational part,
both on the sender side
and the receiver side
to encrypt and decrypt the traffic.
Along with that,
the security of the key is
of paramount importance here.
Because God forbid, if
this key gets into the hand
of an attacker,
they will have visibility
into the entire communication
between the sender and the receiver.
That's why companies spend
large amount of resources
to build infrastructure that
can keep these keys secure
and that can rotate these keys regularly
so that in case of a compromise,
the blast radius is limited.
So AWS long back itself,
AWS had recognized the challenges
in implementing encryption
and building these secure
key management systems.
And we started offering native encryption
across multiple paths.
So next we'll discuss
the native encryption
that AWS offers across different paths.
So today, all your traffic
between any two AWS data
centers is encrypted
using state of the art
Advanced Encryption Standard
with the 256 bit key,
whenever this traffic leaves
AWS secured facilities.
And this encryption is implemented
between data centers in
an availability zone,
across availability zone,
and even across regions.
And then the traffic is
transmitted between regions.
If you're using transit gateway pairing
or if you're using cross region pairing,
then all the traffic
gets an additional layer
of bulk encryption on top of
the native AES 256 encryption.
And you may have noticed
that I've been saying
that this traffic is encrypted
when it leaves the AWS secured facilities,
and these facilities are really secured
because there's physical
security present there,
and no unauthorized person can just walk
into these buildings.
But there's no such
thing as more security.
So back in 2019, we
launched Nitro encryption
or VPC encryption.
And what that is that today,
any two modern EC2 instances,
when they're communicating
with each other,
all the traffic between
these instances are encrypted
using state of the art AES 256 encryption.
And this encryption holds true even
within your data centers,
even within AWS secured facilities.
So I still remember back in 2019
when we launched Nitro encryption,
back then there were hoards of customers
who upgraded their entire infrastructure
so that they can use this
native Nitro encryption.
The good thing about
this Nitro encryption,
it's transparent to the customer.
No, you don't have to manage
the key infrastructure.
It does not impact the compute power
or the processing power of your compute
or your EC2 instances.
And it just works there transparently.
So even today, a lot of
customers manage Excel workbooks
where they track the
usage of instance types
across their environment.
But tracking it manually
has a couple of challenges.
One is, of course, it's a manual effort
to track the instance usage
across your environment.
The other thing is this encryption,
this native Nitro encryption
works on modern EC2 instances,
but your EC2 instances also communicate
with AWS services or external services,
not many of which may,
not all of which support Nitro encryption.
The other problem is that as
you introduce new workloads,
the number of potential network paths
increases exponentially.
And then tracking and
monitoring encryption
across all these network paths,
it can get really difficult real quick.
That's why AWS launched
VPC Encryption Controls,
two weeks back to
address these challenges.
So VPC encryption controls allows,
it comes in two modes.
One is the monitor mode, the
other is the enforce mode.
It allows you to monitor
the encryption status
of your traffic flows.
It also allows you to identify resources
that are not enforcing
encryption in transit.
And then it gives you the tools
to enforce encryption in
transit within your VPC
and even across your VPCs.
And once you have done that,
you can also create, generate flow logs
for auditing purposes.
Or you can also look at what
VPCs are enforcing encryption
and what VPCs are not
enforcing encryption.
And this feature is really easy to use.
We'll cover it up in
the subsequent slides.
You can literally click a single button
and you can turn on encryption controls
in your existing VPCs or your new VPCs.
You can turn it on during creation itself.
And other thing is it
addresses the other challenge
and it offers native Nitro
encryption beyond EC2 instances
to many AWS services like RDS, Redshift,
Application Load Balancer,
Fargate tasks, etc.
It also works across your VPCs
whenever you're using VPC Peering
or whenever you're using Transit Gateway
and you can exert all
these controls centrally,
and you can create reports
and you can show that you are complying
with different encryption standards.
So let's talk about the different modes
of encryption controls.
You may remember that I
talked about two modes.
There's a monitor mode and
there's an enforce mode.
The reason we will discuss monitor mode
before enforce mode is
because you cannot directly
move an existing VPC
to enforce mode.
And the reason is
because what enforce mode
does is enforce mode ensures
that all your existing resources
are enforcing encryption
in transit.
And it also ensures that
all your future resources
that you will launch,
ever launch in your VPC,
they will also ensure
encryption in transit.
But in order to ensure
encryption in transit
for existing resources,
you first need to identify
what resources are not
enforcing encryption today.
And for that, you need to
first turn on monitor mode.
So turning on monitor
mode is as I promised
in the previous slide,
turning on monitor mode is very easy.
You just select your VPC here,
and then you just turn on
encryption controls here.
And you'll notice that the
enforce mode is grayed out.
It's grayed out for existing VPCs
because you first need to make sure
that all your resources
are encrypting traffic
at resource level.
And this holds true
only for existing VPCs.
By the way, if you're creating a new VPC,
you can always immediately
turn on encryption enforcement
because you don't have
any resources there.
So here, once you turn
on the monitor mode,
we give you a new control
using which you can identify the resources
that may not be enforcing encryption.
So you can go into the console,
VPC encryption controls console,
and you will see that
there are, oh, sorry.
You'll see that there are these resources
which are not encrypting
or which are not enforcing
encryption today.
You can also use the CLI to
identify those resources.
When you look into the screen,
you'll find out not only the resources
that are not enforcing encryption,
but you'll also find out
whether these resources are
eligible for exclusion or not.
So we'll discuss later in the slides
how can you exclude certain resources?
But by exclusion,
what we mean is that there
are certain resources.
For example, there's internet gateway
or virtual private gateway
using which your traffic
transmits outside the boundary
of AWS.
For such resources, you are responsible
to enforce encryption.
So either you can remove
those resources from the VPC
or you can continue
running them as exclusions.
And when you continue
running them as exclusions
and you still go into enforce mode,
what AWS will ensure is
that all future resources
or all existing resources
except these excluded resources
will enforce encryption.
For these resources that are excluded,
you are responsible for
maintaining encryption.
So this is what exclusion does.
And once you have, once you
identify these resources,
we'll also discuss how to
migrate each of these resources
and how to make sure that
they're enforcing encryption.
But before we go there,
the monitor mode also
gives you the ability
to monitor the encryption status
of individual traffic flows.
And you can do that using
your familiar VPC flow logs.
When you turn on VPC flow logs,
we have introduced a new field here
and called encryption status.
You can just turn on encryption status.
And encryption status will
start emitting numerical values
to tell you whether your
traffic is encrypted or not,
or whether it is encrypted
at the application layer
at the physical layer
using Nitro encryption.
So this is how you can
read the encryption status.
When the encryption status is zero,
it means that the VPC encryption controls
has recognized your traffic
flow as unencrypted.
Now, please note
that VPC encryption controls
recognizes the Nitro encryption
at the physical layer
as well as the application
layer encryption only
to AWS services via AWS
PrivateLink interface endpoints
and gateway endpoints.
Now, when it emits a value of one,
it means that your traffic is encrypted
at the physical layer using
the Nitro system hardware.
A value of two means it's
encrypted at application layer.
Again, you'll see the value two,
when you traffic is going to
or coming from AWS services,
which are accessed via gateway endpoints
or interface endpoints.
Now, the numerical three tells you
that the traffic is encrypted
both at the physical layer
by Nitro and at the application layer.
And if you don't get any value,
it means that either you haven't turned
on VPC encryption controls
or flow logs currently does
not have that value with it.
So this is how you monitor
the encryption status,
and this is how you identify resources
which are not enforcing encryption.
Next, let's see how you can turn on
or how you can move
to transition your existing
VPC to enforce mode.
Again, just to repeat,
if you have a new VPC,
you can turn on enforce
mode at creation itself.
But for existing VPCs,
you first need to turn on monitor mode
and you need to identify
the non-compliant resources.
The non-compliant
resources are the resources
that are not enforcing
encryption in transit themselves.
And once you've done that,
the next thing is that you
need to make certain changes
to these resources and you need to ensure
that all these resources
are enforcing encryption.
And you'll see, and we'll discuss that
in the subsequent slide.
You'll see that for many of other sources,
we will take care of encryption
ourselves once you turn
on the encryption controls
even in monitor mode.
And then once you have made sure
that your non all resources,
especially the non-excludable ones,
are enforcing encryption in transit,
that is when you can modify
your encryption controls
to turn on enforce mode,
or you can transition to enforce mode.
So let's look at how you can ensure
that your different VPC resources
are enforcing encryption.
So for many of the resources
such as Fargate task,
Application Load Balancer,
Network Load Balancer,
the moment you turn on encryption controls
in monitor mode itself,
behind the scenes, we'll start
migrating these resources
onto new Nitro hardware so
that they can automatically
and natively support
encryption in transit.
So you don't have to do anything.
Once you turn it on,
we'll take care of it.
It will take some time but we will do it.
For all AWS services except API gateway,
for all AWS services
that are supported by
PrivateLink interface endpoint
or from gateway endpoint,
we'll enforce encryption
at the application layer.
And this, what this means is that
if an application tries to
send unencrypted traffic
to such AWS services, we'll just drop it.
Then there are a host of other services.
These services, which is your EC2
or your auto scaling
groups, or EKS or ECS, etc.,
here, typically you select
the underlying instance type.
So you are responsible for
choosing the modern instances.
For many customers that have talked to,
they're already using modern
instances for these resources.
And if you're doing that, you are all set.
But in case you're using an
older generation instance,
you need to move those
resources onto new hardware
or onto new EC2 instances,
the modern EC2 instances.
Once you do that, they will
also start encrypting traffic
at the physical layer.
And all these resources
lie inside your VPC
and they help you enforce
encryption within the VPC itself.
Now let's talk about what you need to do
if you have a transit gateway
and you also want to encrypt
your traffic across VPCs.
So for transit gateway,
we have introduced a new option
called encryption support.
And you can turn it to enable.
And once you turn it to enable,
even your traffic between your VPCs
that have encryption enforced
will start getting encrypted
at the physical layer itself.
So now once you've moved all your,
once you've moved all these resources
to encryption enforcement,
you can then transition
to enforce mode.
While you are transitioning
to enforce mode,
the console will give
you the list of resources
that are unencrypted, will
also give you the resource,
the list of resources that
are eligible for exclusion.
You can turn on exclusion
for those resources
and then you can turn on enforce mode.
Once you turn on enforce
mode, the VPC does two things.
One, it makes sure
that your existing
resources always communicate
in encrypted traffic.
And the second thing it
does is it makes sure
that any future resources
that you instantiate inside this VPC
are always enforcing encryption.
It won't allow you to
launch older generation
of EC2 instances, which
do not support encryption.
So that is what enforce mode does.
After turning on enforce mode,
you basically, this allows
you to enforce encryption
within the VPC.
But next we'll discuss how
can you ensure encryption
across VPCs using VPC
peering and transit gateway.
So whenever you're using VPC peering,
suppose if you have two VPCs,
and both those VPCs have
encryption controls turned on
in enforce mode without any exclusion,
you can peer these VPCs
and all communication
between these VPCs will
always be encrypted.
However, even if one of those
VPCs has any exclusions,
or if one of those VPCs has
encryption controls turned on
in monitor mode or is turned off,
then in order to turn on peering
with an encryption enforced VPC,
you need to create an
exclusion for that peering.
And what that means is that this VPC,
the VPC on the left hand side,
this is going to encrypt all
traffic except the traffic
that's going to the peering connection.
The traffic, which is going
to the peering connection,
the encryption status of
that traffic would depend
on the resources that are
communicating with each other.
For example, if you have modern
EC2 instances on both sides,
or you have services that are running
on top of modern EC2 instances,
then this traffic will be encrypted.
But in case if this resource
tries to communicate
with another resource
that's running on an older
generation of EC2 instance
then the traffic won't be encrypted.
So this is what how you
can turn on encryption
between your encryption enforced VPCs.
But if you want more
flexibility here, for example,
if you want this VPC which
is encryption enforced
to be connected to a different VPC
which is not encryption enforced,
and still make sure that all traffic
within this VPC is encrypted,
that's when you need
to use transit gateway.
So this is what happens when
you use transit gateway.
You can turn on encryption
controls on your transit gateway.
When you, enable encryption
controls on your transit gateway
and you peer to VPCs, what you
can do is you can peer a VPC
that has encryption
controls running without,
in enforce mode, without any exclusion.
And you can peer it with a VPC
which is not encryption enforced.
And the solid line here
represents the encrypted traffic
and the broken line represents the traffic
that may or may not be encrypted.
So in this case, what would
happen is within this VPC,
which is encryption enforced,
all your traffic will be encrypted,
even the traffic that's
going to the transit gateway.
Now, the traffic is encrypted
through the transit gateway attachment
in your encryption unenforced VPC.
And only the last leg of the traffic,
which is between the
transit gateway attachment
and your resource
in the unenforced,
encryption unenforced VPC,
that will depend on the resource type
that the transit gateway
is communicating with.
So this is
how you can use this new
feature VPC encryption controls
to enforce encryption within
your VPCs and across your VPCs.
Next I'll hand it over to Scott
who will discuss the different
encryption strategies
and he'll talk about the
emerging encryption frontier.
Thank you everyone.
- Thanks, Akshay.
So let's talk about encryption strategies.
We've all seen,
or hopefully most of us have seen
the famous Werner Vogels shirt that Akshay
and I are wrapping today,
encrypt everything, right?
But encrypt everything is a
goal. It's not a strategy.
So how do we actually get to that goal?
Encryption layering is the answer to this.
And what I've found is
that interestingly you can
match encryption layering
to the OSI model.
If you're not familiar with OSI model,
it gives us seven layers of networking.
Some will say eight, I don't know who,
anyways, with seven layers of networking
from physical all the way to application.
And what we find is
that these different protocols
work at different layers.
So we have Optical Line
Encryption or MACsec encryption
between our AWS secured facilities
like Akshay was talking about earlier.
This exists without you
having to do anything.
You can also use MACsec encryption
on your direct connect connections
if you have a supported connection, right?
You can check this in your
direct connections and enable it.
Then we can move up the
stack into the network layer,
that layer three, kind of IP layer, right?
And we get into AWS Nitro encryption
that Akshay was talking about
which we can enforce
using encryption controls
and using modern instances.
We also get some tunneling
technology like IPSec,
WireGuard, OpenVPN.
You can find IPSec and OpenVPN
and AWS Site-to-Site VPN
and AWS Client VPN.
And you can use these to encrypt
between on-premise locations,
various end user locations
and your AWS VPC.
Then we get TLS. TLS is really great.
It's really performant.
It encrypts kind of in that
layer four through six area.
Hard to really define
where and there it is.
So I just kinda left it for all of them
and we'll leave that
debate for another day.
And this is supported through
your customer applications,
Amazon VPC Lattice, if
you're not familiar with it,
there's some great sessions this week.
Go look at them.
Elastic Load Balancer, CloudFront
and many more services support TLS.
And then we get into
application level encryption.
Things like SSH that exist out there,
client side encryption.
You may use something like our
key management service, KMS
to do that.
A lot of different ways to do that,
but it really kind of moves up the stack
and using multiple layers
is gonna help you make sure
that all of your traffic is encrypted,
that you're really encrypting everything.
So let's look at the characteristics
of these different encryption protocols.
So again, we have MACsec
at the data link layer,
performance really high.
Typically this is implemented
in hardware, right?
With hardware acceleration, ASICs or FPGAs
that are doing the
encryption at line rate.
It's a hop by hop
encryption though, right?
That means that between
every two layer device
or layer two devices,
that's where the encryption
stops, gets decrypted
and then re-encrypted, right?
So thinking of direct connect
between your on-premise router
and the direct connect switch,
it's gonna be encrypted,
then it's gonna get de-encrypted
and all that AWS switch.
And then when we leave
an AWS secured facility,
we're again going to encrypt
with optical line encryption
or MACsec encryption, right?
So it's a hop by hop
characteristic, right?
And we can manage this
by the networking team typically, right?
Then we get into IPSec.
IPSec tends to be a
little less performant,
just dependent on where
you're terminating it, right?
If you have that hardware
acceleration, it's great.
One of the kind of
downsides to IPSec though is
that it's an encapsulation protocol,
which means you're cutting off
that maximum transmission unit, MTU.
So over the internet
or even over direct connect,
AWS Site-to-Site VPN,
you're gonna see an MTU
somewhere in the neighborhood
of 1433 bytes, maybe a little
less, maybe a little more,
just depending on what what you're doing.
But that's gonna be less, right?
Which means when we start getting
into higher latency environments,
your performance is gonna go down, right?
So you gotta really think
about that usage there.
But you can get some very
performant connections as well.
We actually just released
five gigabit per second,
or up to five gigabit per second tunnels
on AWS Site-to-Site VPN,
which is really cool.
I've been seeing this team work on this
for a number of years.
And this is a point to point connection,
meaning that where you
terminate the IPSec tunnel
on each side is where it's gonna go.
So it's spanning multiple
hops, but it's not end to end.
It's not from server
to server necessarily.
Could be, but not usually.
Then we get into network
encryption, right?
Nitro, the security team
can now control this
using VPC encryption controls
and setting those VPC
encryption controls, right?
So now we've taken things
from the networking team
and given some capability
to the security team
to enforce encryption.
This is again, point to point.
It's gonna be from an AWS EC2 instance
to an AWS EC2 instance, right?
So if there's multiple hops in
there, like transit gateway,
there will be some points
in there where it decrypts
and where it encrypts, so on and so forth.
TLS, right? This is
super performant, right?
Because every individual
session gets encrypted
with a different key,
gets hashed against
multiple processing cores,
just a absolutely performant protocol.
Honestly, most things today
should be using TLS, right,
most of your applications.
But it's hard to manage
and hard to enforce
because it's on the
application owner typically
to enforce this, right?
So you really gotta think through
how you enforce this and how you audit it.
And that's where multi-layer encryption
comes into play, right?
'Cause the networking team
has an enforcement point,
the security team has an enforcement point
and the application owner has
an enforcement point, right?
So everybody gets a little
piece of the pie to make sure
that we're getting fully encrypted.
And then application layer encryption.
This tends to be something like,
encrypting individual packets
with something like KMS.
And it's really hard to implement
this in a performant way.
If you wanna be really,
really super secure
and try and do it, you definitely can.
But for most things in
transit, TLS, Nitro,
turn type of tunneling protocol,
MACsec, Optical Line Encryption,
this is where you're gonna get
the most bang for your buck
as compared to, you know, kind
of client side encryption.
KMS is better for more
encryption at rest, right,
than encryption in transit.
So let's talk about emerging
encryption frontiers, right?
Akshay brought up earlier
the history of encryption.
And we've come a long way.
And so we're now getting into
post quantum cryptography.
And so everyone sees this
and they think this magical thing, right?
Quantum's all magic, right?
No one really knows what it means.
But because quantum cryptography
is all about the fact
that in theory there may be some future
where a quantum computer
could potentially break RSA
or elliptical curve, right?
There's not one that we know of
in existence today that's done it.
Not powerful enough.
They haven't reached enough entanglement
to be able to do that,
enough qubits, right?
But we think that maybe
there's some future
where that could exist.
And before we get to that future,
the industry as a whole has been studying
how do we make encryption safe
so that if someone's storing those packets
that they can't go
decrypt them later, right?
For most people not
really concerned, right?
'Cause your data's
probably not worth enough
to store all that data forever.
For some people it's
very important, right?
Governments, financial services,
other things like that, right?
So it just depends on what you're doing,
but it's one of those things
that we're starting to think about, right?
And AWS has started
taking it really seriously
and we've started releasing
services that support
Module-Lattice-based
Key-Encapsulation-Mechanism.
It's a mouthful.
So to explain what that is, right?
We do a key exchange
and we use asymmetric encryption
to do that key exchange
using RSA or electrical curve
and typically use Diffie-Hellman
to do the key exchange, right,
within that asymmetric path, right?
Once we do that key exchange,
we then get symmetric keys on both sides
and we use those symmetric
keys as performant way
to encrypt the data that's
actually going across it, right?
So we use asymmetric to
exchange symmetric keys
and then symmetric encryption
to actually transport data, that's AES.
AES, we believe, is
quantum safe, especially,
you know, 256, 128 events.
NIST has shown some data
that it shows could be quantum safe,
but RSA and elliptical curve is
where the real concern is, right?
And with perfect forwarding secrecy,
even more so AES is less a concern, right?
So we have different sessions in there.
So we focused on ML
KEM within our services
and how we do that key exchange
and we support it within
KMS, secrets manager,
certificate manager, CloudFront.
We also just released, I
believe last week support
for this in Elastic Load
Balancer or maybe two weeks ago.
But Elastic Load Balancer supports it.
So let's take a trip down
history lane for a second.
Think back to like early two thousands.
Some of you probably don't
wanna think about the year 2000,
some Y2K stuff there.
Some of you maybe have no
idea what I'm talking about.
Don't worry, you can go Google it later.
But if you wanted to support
a new encryption protocol
and your application stack
in the early two thousands,
that was a ton of work, right?
There's a whole refactor, a
whole infrastructure upgrade,
just massive amount of work. With AWS,
if you wanna go support
post quantum cryptography
with these services and the console,
it's a checkbox in your cloud formation,
Terraform, Pulumi, OpenTofu,
whatever else is out there these days.
It's a line or two of code, that's it.
That's all you gotta do.
And then your post
quantum encrypted, right?
As long as your client supports it, right?
And you can support the
multiple encryption protocols,
right? So if your client
doesn't support ML KEM,
then they use RSA or
elliptical curve, right?
And if your client supports ML KEM,
then they upgrade to ML
KEM and use that, right?
And then as your clients
become more modern,
you can just enforce
ML KEM on these things
with your TLS policies.
So it's just really cool
to think about that of like
how hard it was 20 years ago
and how easy it is today.
Quantum key distribution.
Quantum key distribution's,
really, really cool
because it's a way to
prove through physics
that when we exchange a key
over this quantum network
and a tangled network that nobody saw
that key exchange, right?
So we use the Schrodinger principle,
which says that when we
do this key exchange,
if there's someone in the middle
that state's gonna change,
it's gonna flatten out.
And then on the other side we
can see that someone observed
that key exchange and
let's just not use that key
'cause it's compromised, right?
And when you prove it,
it's a law of physics,
you cannot break it.
Really cool, really cool
emerging technology.
And AWS has been studying
quantum key distribution
for years.
You can see down here a
link from several years ago
where we created a QKD network
or a quantum network
over a couple kilometers
and some other research that's going on
in that neighborhood.
And so we're gonna see this
as an emerging technology in AWS.
There's a really great session INV 507,
which if you get a chance,
I suggest you go to.
Just kind of cool thing to
nerd out on if you will.
But it's a great topic
to think about, right,
of like what's next in that key exchange.
How do we make sure that nobody
can observe that key, right?
So what's next? What do you do?
How do we get to encrypt everything?
Take these steps to get
to a more secure future.
Inventory your environment,
inventory it through AWS config,
through VPC encryption controls, right?
Through Security Hub. All
these tools that are available
to you to inventory your environment.
Inventory On-Prem environment.
Understand what's being
encrypted and what's not.
Where is it being encrypted, right?
What's being transmitted?
Is it sensitive data
or is it something that
honestly nobody cares
if it's in plain text, right?
Think about that, inventory it.
Audit it, right?
Go through that inventory and
understand what is important,
what's meeting your requirements, right?
Think through that. Start
enforcing encryption.
How do you enforce it?
You gotta start having that
conversation at the top, right?
You gotta start talking to
your CISOs, to your CIO,
to even your CEO and start
having a conversation
about we need to take encryption seriously
and we need to enforce it.
In AWS, super easy, right?
We have all these things
that are just super easy ways
to onboard to encryption.
On-prem, maybe not so easy
and maybe requires a little
more investment, right?
But start enforcing it.
Remediate those things
that are missing out in your audit, right?
In your inventory and audit.
And then repeat because
things change, right?
Developer went and built some
new cool thing, said, oh yeah,
I'm not gonna use encryption
because that's hard.
And it's just a dev environment.
And of course what happens
to every dev environment
in the world gets promoted
to production and oops, we
forgot to encrypt it, right?
So you gotta continuously
go through this cycle,
continuously inventory, audit,
enforce remediate, repeat.
With that, I'd like to thank
you for coming to our session.
I know that it was during the
lunch hour and kind of the day
before re:Invent starts, so we
really appreciate your time.
If you enjoyed our
session, go into your app,
give us five stars and some feedback.
If you didn't enjoy our
session, go into the app,
give us five star, no, I'm just kidding.
Give us some honest feedback.
We love your feedback.
And if you have any questions,
Akshay and I will be
right outside those doors
across from the content
hub right after this.
We gotta get outta here so
we clear some space out.
But we can meet you over there
and answer any questions you have.
Thank you.